there's a scene in the movie it is so
perfectly representative of what
actually happens I think it's sexy yes
yes Amy you've been out for two years
and you've never kissed a girl
you've done quite a few seconds yourself
as an actress yep how did you coach
Kaitlyn through doing an intimate scene
like that you know I just wanted to make
them feel safe I think that so much of
acting is relaxation and I think a
director's job is to help you do that
and to create an environment where you
can feel safe and relaxed and so I made
it a true closed set which by the way
never happens so what does that mean
they call it a closed set when the
people who are unnecessary in the crew
to that scene just fall back and and and
there's a little bit more privacy but
every time I've done a love scene there
are like 50 people in the room and I'm
like surely not everyone has to be here
so I really made it a priority to make
sure it was very private and to turn off
all the monitors and the rest of the
house the set where we were working and
to keep it truly protected so these
girls knew it was just me the
cinematographer and them everything had
to be as private as possible because I
wanted it to feel real did you give like
specific specific like things that I
will have always wanted to see portrayed
more accurately and love scenes one in
movies everyone like makes out and never
looks at each other I'm like people take
breaths people talk to each other also
it's very hard to get shoes off
particularly converse it's very hard to
take off someone's converse and so that
I was like we are showing the reality
also jeans tight jeans are very hard to
remove right you gotta do a little
withers and Jimmy yeah there's a whole
thing so I was like let's show that part
of the kind of delight in a first
experience is navigating those
complicated moment moment
but I think that this specific sex scene
is so beautiful and it is again a sex
scene that I think everyone should see
because it's not overly sexualized and I
think Olivia really wanted to make sure
of that she wanted to show everything
she wanted to show the awkward moments
because that first hook up with your
crush is is so awkward and there's so
many like weird moments and and untying
converse is is a difficult thing and
then taking off pants is an even more
difficult thing it's it's it's I love it
it's so it's so not it's so not overdone
and it's really honest and beautiful I
think portraying you know teen sexuality
in such a full way of like it's awkward
and it's sexy and it's funny and they
make each other laugh and it's and it's
it's consensual it's all these
incredible things but it's also the
Olivia's in our film she's showing that
through a queer relationship which is so
radical it's just so good and I'm Horton
and and awesome what you two have is
special well probably just do a Korean
face mask I don't need to know all the
words